More than 35 years after The Empire Strikes
Back was released, there's something about
the Star Wars sequel that still doesn't sit
right with Mark Hamill.
At the beginning of the 1980 blockbuster,
Mark Hamill's iconic character Luke Skywalker
is captured by a massive snow beast called
a Wampa on the icy planet of Hoth.
To get away, Skywalker uses his lightsaber
to slice off one of the creature's arms.
But that apparently wasn't what Hamill signed
up for.
Hamill revealed on Twitter he was originally
under the impression that Luke wouldn't actually
hurt the Wampa.
"When filming [the] scene, I was assured my
lightsaber swipe toward camera ([the] creature
[was] not on set) would simply singe [its]
fur [to] scare him off.
Horrified to later see amputation and unnecessary
cruelty.
Wampa was hungry (not evil).
Luke would never do this!"
The comments echo statements Hamill has made
about the scene in the past on his show Mark
Hamill's Pop Culture Quest.
"Then I remember saying, 'Well, I'm just grazing his
fur, right?'
They said, 'what, what do you mean?
I said, well, it's like a hungry bear, he's
not evil.
"Yeah."
"So I should just scare him off."
"Not only did I cut off its arm they did a
insert of it falling in slomotion, I just - I never thought
that was right."
The topic came up when a fan shared a photo
of a cake made to look like a severed Wampa
arm for National Cake Day.
But Hamill, an outspoken animal lover, said
he's still angry about the scene.
Of course, the special edition of Empire Strikes
Back has an even more graphic version with
the Wampa shown bloody and screaming.
A Twitter user responded that it all seemed
gratuitous.
"Heck, it was even in the book.
Luke used the force to sense the Wampa's mind."
Hamill replied, "My acting was much better
in the book."
This isn't the first time Luke's battle with
the Wampa has made headlines, as a deleted
scene from Empire Strikes Back seemed to suggest
the fight was added to explain the facial
scars Hamill suffered in a 1977 car accident.
"Bacta is growing real well.
. Scars oughta be gone in a day or so."
We'll find out how Luke feels about a whole
new batch of creatures when Star Wars: The
Last Jedi hits theaters on December 15.
Hopefully, he's kinder to Porgs than Chewbacca
is.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know you'll love, too!